so hi how are you doing today
good thank you first I want to ask
what's it like doing comedy with Steve
Carell Wow intimidating I have had a
long-standing acting crush on him so I
was like oh I'd screw this up and I
finally I had a same if Nancy his wife
years ago in bridesmaids she was in the
Tennessee Kristen and I Nancy was um was
my partner in the scene my tennis
partner and she was awesome so and such
a funny actress and comedian but yeah
working with state was so nerve-racking
yeah I mean he's such a professional and
lovely and you know um but my first
scene that I shot was when I look at his
face
couldn't do that see now you've been
great in so many comedies and I was
wondering what's it like working with
John as opposed to Paul Feig or nicholas
stoller you know it was such a specific
world of satirizing the political
machine so to be in his hands was just a
pleasure I've long been a fan of that
genre I loved broadcast news I really
enjoyed the newsroom I loved you know
it's you know this my minded thinking
but um so it was I really was thrilled
to be part of this genre and to have to
be in the hands of someone like John so
in that way it was really unique and I
kind of can't compare it in that sense
cuz it was such a specific genre did you
have to do any research talking the real
political consultants or was it more
about the cartoonish villainy of this
character well immediately John pointed
me to the very famous documentary the
war room by da Pennebaker yet and so
there's a great dynamic between Mary
Mallon and James Carville who are in a
relationship and there we see from
opposite sides but they have this great
chemistry and sparring thing and this
delight in their competition and clearly
there's like a sexiness between them and
that I think was a big inspiration for
faith and Gary is it more fun too
play kind of this kind of outlandish
villain character or do you prefer so
playing someone who's a little more
grounded in reality well I never want to
say to an audience she's the villain
first start that's you're entitled to
your opinion but I think I think the
piece as a whole is what attracted me to
the project like I say the genre of the
newsroom to work with John to work with
Steve and I am fascinated by these sorts
of characters by megan kelly or kelly
anne Conway or this sort of cult of
personality that has really evolved over
the last few the last decade I guess you
know it's been almost a decade since
damages wrapped and I was kind of
wondering what your memories that were
of that show my memories are really kind
of emotional I'm just talking to Glenn
the other day actually about we were
checking in and you know she's still a
dear friend and it's just so surreal I
mean it changed my life in many ways my
memories are of us working together of
us getting scripts that morning and
trying to learn them of the fun of
working with Glenn every day you know
she's just she's such an incredible
actress which I don't need to tell you
but was that fun I'm sparring with her
and the I loved being part of a thriller
it was really fun to have the twists and
turns of a TV show and the excitement of
the table reads and the next episodes
and that I I miss it yeah well thank you
so much for taking the time to talk with
me today I really appreciate it